[Musique]
xavier passe mal bonjour jour tu es bien
oui je vais bien et moi super mais en
moins bon génial pour il ça dure vous
êtes ici en tant que versaillais vous
êtes ici parce que j'avais une grosse
actu qui va bientôt arriver vous allez
ouvrir votre premier restaurant et on va
raconter un peu votre histoire
nous on a eu la chance d'avoir six
monnaies des anonymes prêts on a eu jean
baptiste la vanoise unis donc vous êtes
notre troisième chef pourquoi ça peut la
mouvance ça c'est un peu le groupe de
versailles où elle a travaillé tous les
trois se sont dit que j'ai pris un peu
de temps
oui dis à personne ouais c'est là ça y
est je le dis à personne
et là je le dis à tout le monde joue mon
restaurant c'est officiel à l'officiel
donc c'est un scoop
basescu mais exactement merci beaucoup
et dites moi on va remonter un tout
petit peu dans le temps
d'où vous vient cet amour cet intérêt
cette passion pour la cuisine
vos parents sont dans leur métier non
pas du tout en fait les bancs étaient
dans l'imprimerie et jouait jamais mais
pas ans qui travaillait beaucoup et en
fait je me métin pour leur faire plaisir
je faisais la cuisine à la maison et des
qui rentrait vers 21h ma short et mes
plats alors c'était bon c'était pas bon
ça dépend des jours et après j'allais au
marché à versailles avec mon père a jeté
les langoustines ou des bons produits et
après on est transformé en les cuisiner
avec ma mère d'après mon passé à tabac
il compte 15 heures c'était important
voire très important des bons produits
prendre le temps de cuisiner d'être
ensemble d'échanger de partager partager
toute la famille bas la cuisine c'est la
famille et pour la famille c'est sacré
c'est le moment où tout le monde est
réuni et est donc c'est dans votre adn
donc ce n'est pas très étonnant que vous
ayez choisi finalement cette voie de le
chef vous avez fait t comme âge kwassa
tecomah mais j'ai arrêté l'école à 14
ans et après je suis parti tout de suite
en école de cuisine est ce que vous
savez déjà ce que vous aviez après un
stage de 3e tout ça j'étais au méridien
magnifique j'ai dit on arrête le match
le français c'est pas bon on fait la
cuisine c'est sa r et c'est un marché je
compte ans v d'une quatre ans d'études
et les brasseries parisiennes
chez les traiteurs
je fais tous tous les styles de cuisine
toutes les étapes
moi aussi je crois vous avez commencé
comme commis comme tout le monde que oui
messieurs et après j'ai toujours voulu
aller le plus loin possible dans la
gastronomie donc je suis resté assez
longtemps au trianon palace avec la
simone zanoni et là qu'est ce qui s'est
passé qu'est-ce qu'il a fait si manier
giannoni à d'anonymat il m'a il m'a
ouvert les portes de ma place de chef
aujourd'hui il m'a beaucoup aidé c'est
une personne qui m'a il a eu confiance
en moi parce que j'étais son sous-chef
way au trianon palace et après je suis
je suis passé à la télévision pour me
wade vous inscrire inscrit à tokyo ouais
c'était de votre plein gré s'effectuer
qui vous ai dit tiens je sais que tu es
capable de le faire celui il m'a dit
fais le tu es prêt moi je ne me sentais
pas prêt derniers temps je suis assez je
suis assez timide des choses comme ça je
suis pas trop je n'aime pas trop
m'exposer à la télé et il m'a dit a fait
le buzz
ils y croient mais j'y suis allé bah
j'avais j'avais peur de le décevoir ce
soit parce que j'avais peur de décevoir
mes parents et mon équipe parce que
j'étais quand même sous chef
j'avais dégâts et avait quinze gars
derrière moi non plus mais de gordon
surtout quand on cerne qui rend la et
aussi simulé zanoni qui pour moi c'était
comme on est pas en quoi ses
débattements tard ima c'est lui qui m'a
tout appris ma forme et d'ailleurs comme
son petit poulain c'est très mignon bon
bref vous avez gagné c'était en 2016 ce
sens est donc là plein phare sur vous
sur versailles sur la restauration
versaillais ça
beaucoup parler ça a changé ma vie au
moins un minimum quand même mais sur
l'album voilà
et à partir de quel moment vous êtes dit
je veux ouvrir mon restaurant mais en
fait je les dis à personne j'ai jamais
voulu ouvrir mon restaurant parce que
j'ai toujours voulu être chef dans un
palace c'était mon rêve d'enfant on a tu
casse tout ça c'était whaou
incroyable finalement il y a il ya quoi
ya deux ans je me suis dit mais en fait
si j'ai un patron toujours je pourrais
jamais faire ce que je veux dans ma
cuisine
ce qu'il faut savoir que les directeurs
ils ont leur leur mot à dire et tout
seul et cela alors j'ai voulu faire ma
cuisine je vais essayé d'ouvrir mon
restaurant et au final bas et cherche
ouais j'ai voulu la liberté de la
créativité et le risque et le risque et
tout ça quoi
et la fierté aussi d'ouvrir mon
établissement
j'ai cherché pendant deux ans sans rien
dire à paris à versailles paris me
faisait rêver les versailles me manquait
donc je vais aussi dit bon bah on va
retourner à versailles pas loin de chez
moi
quartier notre dame il a eu un coup de
coeur sur un établissement en
établissement d'angle il est situé au 10
boulevard du roi et ça pour moi c'est
une belle adresse
je suis aidé à bâtir un établissement
d'angle c'est intéressant balle 6e des
pratiques et pour moi c'est plus joli
que c'était face à dire je vais
travailler sur deux terrains sont plus
optimistes
dites moi c'est quoi votre comment dire
quelle est votre philosophie en tant que
chef qu'est ce que vous voulez faire
partager au niveau des plats déjà qu'est
ce qu'on va manger chez vous en fait je
fais cette en gastronomie où on
travaille beaucoup les menus dégustation
et après moi j'ai beaucoup j'ai beaucoup
réfléchi sur la cuisine et mon style je
me suis dit en fait que la cuisine c'est
un peu comme la musique ou un art
similaires c'est à dire qu'on ne peut
pas juger un artiste en écoutant que dix
secondes de chaque chanson pour moi il
faut écouter il faut prendre le temps
d'écouter toutes les toutes les musiques
même règle album entier voilà moi je ne
veux plus faire de menus dégustation
pour le moment parce que lui dégustation
c'est que 10% de chaque plat à la carte
c'est un échantillon
pour moi d'une assiette qui pourrait
être très belle et très complète comme
un oui on peut que le refrain ou écouter
aussi l'intro tout ça je comprends
j'aime beaucoup la musique donc c'est
pour ça que je lise laura mais c'est
bien on comprend bien ouais ça va et je
me suis dit on va travailler sur des
titres des plats vraiment concret des
entrées des plats des desserts d'accord
qu'est ce que c'est que ce plat qu'on
voit d'ailleurs phocéen c'est un plat
donc c'est la raviole de saumon
langoustines et omar que je faisais au
trianon palace était le plat phare avec
simone zanoni gordon ramsay moi et je
leur fais à la télévision et je vais le
refaire dans mon restaurant en entrée
c'est un petit clin d'oeil on change
complètement les goûts et la recette
mais c'est le même c'est avec la même
chose mais avec ma vision du réel où
j'ai racheté la machine où je me suis
tué le bras pendant sept ans ou tous les
jours manuel la même je veux pas
l'automatique je veux la manif est en
fait tous les jours
frêche la raviole les fait tous les
jours avant le service à 18h pour 19h30
bon d'accord on m'a écouté on note si
notre super est alors tout à l'heure on
a vu passer une énorme plaque de granit
dans les verres noah qu'on va sûrement
revoir à l'écran voilà qu'est ce que
c'est que cette plaque
alors ça c'est un coup de coeur aussi
c'est à dire que bon voilà
financièrement c'est un restaurant c'est
pas facile mais on a des coups de coeur
c'est vrai que ça c'est pas donné mais
j'ai fait très plaisir je me suis fait
plaisir parce qu'elle va servir cette
table parce qu'en fait j'ai mon
restaurant j'ai voulu faire une cuisine
ouverte mais pas simplement une cuisine
ouverte c'est à dire que le pass
c'est-à-dire là où je dresse toutes les
assiettes
là où tout se passait au trianon et tout
en fait je me suis refait la même
cuisine qu au trianon
mais devant les clients ce que je pense
que les clients doivent voir notre façon
de travailler et je même les faire venir
à moi et même les faire dresser quelques
plats avec moi s'ils veulent et je peux
les battre
et voilà non mais attention aux écoles
mais ce que je veux aussi c'est partager
mon savoir faire mon métier
ce soit un restaurant où on est assez
ouvert je veux pas que
j'en cherche chez moi je veux que les
gens soient à l'aise comme comme je le
suis c'est dès que je mets ma baisse de
chef
moi je suis hyper content je suis pas
chez les gens on va vous apporter des à
cette fin les plats commandés par les
clients salon va vous les a portés sur
cette plaque magnifique ça donc c'est un
granit qui a 100 millions d'années qui
vendent du madagascar est en fait qu il
a déridé sens dedans c'est à dire que ya
tout le temps des reflets c'est la pièce
maîtresse de mon resto je lui ai acheté
à versailles une souci ça c'est bien ce
que j aime le travail
attendez on termine juste donc les gens
enfin où vous apporter à cette vous vous
terminez voulait dresser et après c'est
vous les envoyer avec votre chef de
salle en salle récupère les assiettes
les dresse à table et je vais aussi
faire le service sans un minimum parce
que c'est à ce moment là que je vais
changer que l'accusé absent que c'est
très important pour vous le contact et
l'échangé avec mais pendant un moment je
vous mettais vraiment ému tienne c'est à
dire que je veux communiquer pendant que
je pratique il y en avait travaillé nord
c'est à dire que je veux découpé en
salle je veux flambée je veux fumer je
veux je dirais que ouais je ce soit
animé est en fait là on ouvre le
restaurant et on veut monter crescendo
crescendo crescendo c'est à dire que là
on va commencer petit kart bien
maîtrisée et après on va se mettre de
plus en plus de risques
est ce que c'est un petit peu notre
enjeu on veut pas s'endormir vous par
ici noah qu'il m'avait dit que vous
voulez que le public soit assez mélangé
à savoir tous les âges tous les
complètement les toutes les bosses
vous faites un plat un platini en fait
un plat du jour pas dormir moi je veut
mélanger tous les styles je suis comme
ça j'aime bien le mélange est que tous
les toutes les personnes sur cette terre
est là encore très cher donc je je veux
faire 1-1 pelade accroche à 17 euros
voilà qui est abordable là on vous voit
que c'est heureux mais c'est la lime je
vous avais vraiment tout choisir tout de
même avec des fournisseurs français je
crois tout est français un peu d'italie
oui ans beaucoup d'europe en tout cas
les assiettes je voulais pas acheter les
assiettes que tout le monde a donc je
suis allé à limoges chercher mes
assiettes et en plus financièrement
aller sur place c'est moins cher mais
qu'en fait il faut être intelligent
quand on ouvre une affaire faut aller
chercher qu'à faire le bon partout les
mots qui est super et c'était la maison
alors le resto il va s'appeler le
pansement
ouais voilà il ouvre bientôt on peut
dire fin fin juin deuxième quinzaine de
juin exactement voilà france taye vous
avez du pain sur mesure où si vous avez
l'intention qui vient de la boulangerie
de guy nom et rue de la paroisse c'est
un ami qui peut me faire du pain sur
mesure ce magnifique qu'est ce qu'ils
ont de particulier c'est un bon on a
fait une recette qui m'appartient
aujourd'hui donc c'est un pain au maïs
avec la polenta dessus est aussi un pain
bio tradition classique qui sera chaud
et frais à chaque service
18h30 voit la boulangerie ou d'accord
mais là c'est déjà là où il se met au
québec où theo bos est plein de succès
bravo merci
belle initiative et puis ça va être
génial on a hâte de venir se régaler
chez vous aujourd'hui les vrais plats
copieux copieurs tira sans avoir faim
voilà et on travaillera le homard et
j'espère en faire un plat signature la
place signature mais je dois le trouver
mon plat signature c'est pas facile ça
veut dire quoi exactement
ça veut dire que dans je pense que quand
j'aurai 40 ans j'ai vraiment trouvé là
vous allez maintenant si on peut dire
qu'il me reste encore quelques années à
faire et je veux que les gens se disent
bon bah et xavier pincement ce légal ce
plat on va aller manger le et je trouve
que le homard ça marche bien avec moi
c'est vrai vous avez un feeling avec le
homard exactement mais écoutez génial on
a hâte de voir un gros merci clavier des
doigts dessus vous êtes vraiment sûr les
statiques bloc alors on va on va venir
vous voir avec plusieurs à très bientôt
à bientôt
merci passe pas au revoir
[Musique]
donc